the way that the media you know in
collusion with tech companies in
collusion with the FBI as we now know
thanks to the Twitter files lock down
that story and the fact that it has
become so obvious that it was true I
mean it was obviously it was true when
it actually was being written but the
way the media covered it and then what
we now know has just made that just so
clear to everyone that if if that moved
a few thousand votes a couple you know
30 000 votes that would have made an
enormous difference in the election and
the fact that they did that that will
stick with people I think and that you
know it's it's a media story but it's a
politic story
yeah uh there there was a poll done on
that as well a very large percentage of
Biden voters had absolutely no idea
about the the hunter Biden story and
about 10 of people who voted for buy new
reserve it said if they had known about
the hunter Biden laptop story they would
not have voted for Joe yeah I think it
was like 16 but that was enough to have
swung the election depending on where
those orders were